la mejor manera de describir lo que es
khan academy en la actualidad es un
recurso o una herramienta si ustedes van
al sitio podrán ver vídeos ejercicios
interactivos herramientas para
profesores y por lo tanto puede ser
usado por profesores para ayudar a sus
estudiantes también puede ser usado por
alguien que aprende desde su casa y
quiere aprender cosas de manera
independiente puede ser usado por una
persona adulta que le interesa recordar
algunos conceptos que son relevantes
para algo que esté trabajando en este
momento pero algo que quiero dejar claro
es a donde queremos llegar con la
plataforma este no es el objetivo final
ni tampoco es como los estudiantes deben
experimentar el aprendizaje esto es solo
la primera versión y es una versión muy
primitiva actualmente de una herramienta
que eventualmente queda en el poder de
una visión realmente interactiva de la
educación otra cosa que quiero dejar muy
claro aquí que esto no es algo de uso
exclusivo no es que se trate de algo
físico contra algo virtual o algo como
amazon contra barnes noble lo vemos como
algo que es
para apoyar a lo físico cómo podemos
usar las herramientas y recursos del
programa virtual para que la experiencia
de aprendizaje en física sea la mejor
posible y en esta visión de cómo puede
ser la experiencia integral educativa
tenemos un par de filosofías básicas una
es la idea de dominar lo que se aprende
y lo escribo entre comillas porque
dominio puede significar diferentes
cosas para diferentes personas para
nosotros es la idea general de que los
estudiantes deben tener una comprensión
profunda de los conceptos básicos e
ideas fundamentales antes de continuar o
de pasar a otras ideas derivadas oa
ideas más avanzadas si pensamos en la
progresión tradicional de matemáticas la
progresión tradicional en matemáticas
comienza con el aprendizaje de la
aritmética básica y luego se pasa
álgebra
después se pasa trigonometría de
geometría y todo lo demás para
finalmente llegar al cálculo lo que
nosotros pensamos que está ocurriendo
para muchos estudiantes y por lo que
muchos estudiantes tienen problemas
trabajando con álgebra y aún más
problemas entendiendo cálculo es que no
tienen el dominio de las ideas
fundamentales nosotros creemos que los
estudiantes deben tener el tiempo
suficiente para dominar la aritmética
incluyendo exponentes y todo lo demás
para que cuando comiencen a aprender a
álgebra ya tendrán una base mejor y
podrán comprender esos nuevos conceptos
y cuando un estudiante tiene un dominio
profundo del álgebra entonces
comprenderá mucho más fácilmente
cálculos de otra manera estamos
empujando a los estudiantes a través de
estos conceptos y lo que terminan
haciendo simplemente para poder aprobar
las materias es tener una comprensión
totalmente superficial comienzan a
buscar patrones tanto de álgebra como de
cálculo que les permitan simplemente
aprobar los exámenes y esto no solamente
es dañino conforme se va avanzando a
ideas más complicadas
también hace que sea virtualmente
imposible usar estas herramientas para
nuestra vida cotidiana en nuestras
mentes es mucho más valioso tener una
comprensión profunda del álgebra y poder
ver el mundo de una forma algebraica que
simplemente aprobara álgebra y medio
comprender cálculo pero sin poder
aplicarlo o entenderlo de manera
profunda la otra idea que está
relacionada con el dominio del
aprendizaje y de hecho no se puede tener
el dominio del aprendizaje si no se
tiene el tiempo suficiente para que cada
uno comprenda a su paso los conceptos
porque si realmente queremos que los
estudiantes dominen alguna materia
tenemos que darles el tiempo y el
espacio para que dominen estos conceptos
tenemos que dejarles que a su propio
ritmo aprendan otra cosa importante de
aprender al propio ritmo es que hace que
el estudiante sea dueño de su
aprendizaje que es algo tremendamente
útil probablemente es la cuestión más
importante que se puede aprender
mientras está en la escuela no
necesariamente es alguna de estas
materias aprender cómo resolver un
sistema de ecuaciones
una integral lo más importante para
aprender en la escuela es aprender a
aprender cómo se hace uno dueño de su
propio aprendizaje cómo se puede volver
uno mismo su guía de aprendizaje cómo
establecer nuestras propias metas y esto
sólo puede ocurrir en un ambiente de
aprendizaje en donde uno aprenda a su
propio ritmo con personas que pueden
guiarlos uno puede decir mira yo quiero
aprender esto y esto es como quiero
aprenderlo y esto es lo que voy a hacer
para lograrlo mi meta es el dominio de
un tema mi meta no es simplemente
aprobar la materia otra de las cosas en
las que creemos firmemente y con la que
hemos trabajado con muchas escuelas
además de estos elementos y el uso de
recursos y herramientas es la idea de
que los estudiantes le enseñen a sus
compañeros estudiantes o lo que llamamos
aprendizaje entre pares aquí hay un
beneficio obvio si tenemos alguna
estudiante alrededor quizás algún
compañero que ya esté avanzando más en
el tema que nos pueda ayudar y ser
nuestro tutor para que nosotros
avancemos en el aprendizaje de este tema
y esto es poderoso no sólo para el
estudiante que recibe el tutor eo
también para el estudiante que funge
como tutor porque una cosa es resolver
muchos problemas y aprender las materias
de manera tradicional pero para
realmente dominar un tema y yo creo que
la mayoría de los docentes estarán de
acuerdo conmigo para dominar un tema hay
que enseñarlo hay que poder saber
explicarlo y ayudar a que otras personas
comprendan ese tema y además se
desarrollen otras habilidades que son
tan importantes como el hacerse
responsables del propio aprendizaje y
estas otras habilidades tangibles las
habilidades de la empatía la habilidad
de poder escuchar a alguien la habilidad
de poder guiar a alguien sin que se
sientan intimidados o inseguros y
finalmente el cuarto principio que nos
guían es la idea de que los estudiantes
y esto va muy de acuerdo con la
experiencia física de que cuando los
estudiantes estén juntos deben poder
interactuar y no estamos hablando de la
interacción con la computadora
hablamos de interacción física entre
ellos interactuar con otros seres
humanos hablar con ellos
sonreír verlos y debe basarse en el
cuestionamiento en la exploración y esto
es algo clave
creemos experimentando con los
campamentos de verano en donde se
realiza esta parte en particular de la
experiencia es porque nosotros creemos
que para que los estudiantes puedan
hacerse dueños de todos estos elementos
y todo esto está relacionado
especialmente con la idea del dominio
necesita de enfrentarse con ideas
necesitan experimentar las tangiblemente
por ejemplo tenemos estudiantes que
aplican la probabilidad de manera
implícita están haciendo una simulación
ellos creen que están haciendo un juego
pero al hacer estas simulaciones y estos
juegos más adelante cuando ellos se
exponen a las ideas académicas más
formales de probabilidad o del valor
esperado ellos ya tienen una comprensión
tangible de esto y también pueden ver el
valor en una representación más formal
yo espero que con esto tengan un
panorama mucho más claro de lo que somos
somos una herramienta son los recursos
en este momento pero nuestra meta es que
esto se use de todas las formas posibles
como parte de un programa formal como un
complemento como una ayuda de revisión
nuestra meta real es como optimizar esta
herramienta mejorarla para que podamos
realmente lograr estos valores de la
experiencia de una educación integral